Is the shock you seem
to be displaying at present
due to the fact
that I appear well-read
and articulate?
Or do you suffer from
some medical ailment
about which
I should be informed?
What's your name?
Eloise Bridgerton.
Pleased to meet you,
Miss Eloise.
I'm Theo Sharpe.
I know.
You know?
As I know, there are several
errors in your arguments
that I must bring
to your attention.
Have you a pencil?
Never mind.
You may borrow mine.
Do not tell me
you've travelled
at this ungodly hour
to offer more corrections
of my writing.
It was the only time I could
leave without being seen.
And on the contrary,
I've come to ask
for your discernment.
-Is that so?
-Do not look so pleased.
It is a rare occurrence that
I doubt shall be repeated.
I have questions
about the writings
in this pamphlet.
Well, the ideas
can tax a fragile mind.
Perhaps your means
of communicating them
leaves much to be desired.
Or perhaps you
have not seen enough
of the world
to make sense of them yet.
What of Lady Whistledown?
She speaks on everyone
without remorse.
No, no,
she does not speak of all.
Perhaps she simply
does not know
that there are some
beyond the ton
worthy of attention too.
Why are you speaking
of Mr. Sharpe again, El?
I have heeded your warnings.
Theoretically.
It would be foolish of me
to continue to visit him.
And what in actuality?
I visited him
just the other day,
but it's not nearly
as scandalous
as you make it out to be.
It is only his thoughts
I am interested in.
It is a friendship then?
Of course.
What else could it be?
You have come quite a long
way to ask me something,
so go on.
I have thoughts.
I can see how that
might pose a problem
for someone in your world.
Thoughts I would
like to share…
with you.
And are you not
sharing them now?
What I am failing
to say is that often
when I read
something new or…
interesting or provoking,
it is you
who crosses my mind.
It is you I would like
to speak with
about those thoughts.
I see.
And so I am wondering if…
you might also
have thoughts of me
when you think.
I've read all of these.
And?
And…
I set them aside for you.
I thought… perhaps you might
share your thoughts on them.
People from the palace
have been asking about me.
I was almost
thrown out today.
Yes, I think
that may be my fault.
The Queen, she… she saw me
visiting you the other day
and now believes me to be
Lady Whistledown herself.
Ridiculous, yes?
What is ridiculous
is the fact
that you thought it wise
to come back here again.
Come for more books,
did you?
What?
No, I…
came to make sure
you were alright,
to get our story straight.
Our story?
This is not the least
bit surprising.
What is that supposed
to mean?
It means that you are a lady
who has never had to endure
any real difficulties
in your life.
You may have the protection
of your family,
of your society, but I'm…
I do not.
You have taken pleasure from
low life, Miss Bridgerton.
Now I think it best
you return to Mayfair
before you get me
into any more trouble.
You got my note?
Why did you not
tell me sooner?
Why did you continue
lying to me,
carrying on with me
when you knew
this entire time
that the real
Lady Whistledown
has been using
this very shop
to print her scandal sheet.
I couldn't tell you.
Not when she was
still watching me.
Why do you think I ended
things how I did with you
despite wanting to do
the very opposite?
I did not want her to see
the two of us together.
I did not want her
to write cruelly of you.
Little late for that.
I owe you an apology,
Miss Bridgerton…
for everything.
Whistledown's now taken
her business elsewhere.
Thought you'd deserve
to know the truth.
I deserve more than that.
Forgive me.
I'm…
This is absurd.
I would never…
This whole thing,
it is absurd. I…
We cannot continue
to meet like this.
This was your idea.
I know. I…
I know it was.
And… and I'm sorry
for wasting your time.
Are you?
Or are you suddenly
dropping out of this hunt
for other reasons?
People are already
talking about us, Theo.
I do not normally care what
other people think, but yes,
I care about you.
And if we continue
on like this…
I could not live with myself
if you are the one who has
to face the consequences.
I should have known…
that you could not
be any different
from all the other ladies.
It's alright,
Miss Bridgerton.
You dipped your toe
into my waters,
trying to make yourself
feel better
about the unearned
advantages of your birth.
Now you can go
back to your life
and I can go back to mine.
I'm sorry I couldn't
help you find your writer.